[Music]
like to hear yourself talk backs better
than any man I know uh hey guys I'm
Courtney teza now and we're taking a
look at the hottest Hollywood stars who
have even hotter Irish accents while
promoting his film the light between
oceans Michael Fassbender told et he's
not your average Irishman the actors in
touch with his softer side I like fit an
Irishman's willing to admit that we
don't cry sexy and sophisticated
Brooklyn star sheersha Ronan teaches us
how to master her native tongue you need
to keep the sounds quite open so
everything sort of sounds quite melodic
and sing something teig
tying yep name name Nick but it's mean
Finn there's liam neeson who says he's
neutralized his accent over the years
okay here's how I grew up speaking okay
dude corns all right Aaron Joe ray hi
I'm Liam Neeson hi I'm from bottom in
eternity honour and I talk like that so
you've had food in your mouth
Daniel day-lewis Colin Farrell and u2's
Bono make our list too
[Music]
and co-star Cillian Murphy and Jamie
Dornan could have fooled us in the film
anthropoid this is not a night off for
us take a look around you always a bit
anxious when you're doing an accident
scene oh that's a bit nerve-racking for
every actor I think as much as we love
Jamie known for playing Christian Grey
in Fifty Shades on screen
take him off it's his word the accent
off screen that won us over
take my arse why it's terrible the sick
to achieve
[Music]
you